you've
written an interesting blog post if we
take a step
out of the realm of bits and into this
the realm of governance you wrote a blog
post about making algorand
governance decentralized now can you
explain what that means the philosophy
behind that
you know how do you decentralize
basically all aspects
of this kind of system well the
philosophy
and how let's start with a philosophy so
i really believe
that nothing fixed
lasts very long and and so i really
believe
that life is about intelligent
adaptation things change and we have to
be nimble and adjust to change and
when i when i see a lot of of a
crypto project actually very proud to
say it's fixed in stone
um right you know code is law law is
called a verifier of the code that will
never change
you go wow when i'm saying this is a
recipe to me of disaster not immediately
but soon just imagine you take an ocean
liner
and you want to go i don't know from
lisbon to new york and you set the
course
iceberg no iceberg tempest not tempest
and all
it doesn't matter you keep on going but
it's not the way you need
a teal you need to correct you need to
adjust
and um and so on um by the way with the
sign algorithm with the idea
that the code was evolving
as the needs and of course however is a
system
in which and every time there is an
adjustment you must have
essentially a vote that right now is uh
orchestrated at 90 percent of the stake
they say okay we are ready we agree on
the next
version and we pick up this version so
we are able to evolve without
losing too many components left and
right but
i think without evolving any system
essentially become aesthetic
and it's going to shrivel and die sooner
or later
and and so that is um is needed and
what you want to do under the blockchain
you have a perfect
platform in which you can log
your wishes your votes your thing so
that you have a guarantee that
whatever vote you express is actually
seen by everybody else
so everybody sees really the outcome or
call it of a referendum
of a change and vette is in my opinion
a system that wants to live long as to
adapt
you